what I'm an expert in is creating
computerized systems that can assess
things with really great resolution and
really great sensitivity and so we've
had some partners in Australia who are
working in both rugby league and rugby
union who have come to us and they've
said look we've got a lot of guys for
taking hits we're concerned about player
welfare and we want a better way of
understanding how that hits that they're
taking are affecting them in the
long-term not just in a short-term and
how those hits that maybe aren't
concussive but a sub-concussive are also
influencing their ability to function
both on the field and off the field
what we're really trying to do with
these tests is hack the brain the first
way that we do that is with smooth eye
tracking what's going to happen is this
system is going to track my eye
movements and so long as I am following
the scene in the way that we want the
person to follow the scene which is a
smooth pursuit movement I'll hear music
to sort of give me the indication that
I'm doing the right thing this reflex is
a gateway into lower brain function and
we can start to understand exactly how
some of our more reflexive brain
functions and our higher brain functions
are responding by whether or not you can
actually perform this task we're using
the oculus rift to look at balance
ability it's an extremely low-cost
device that has an accelerometer
gyroscope built into it and so what
we've done with our software is we've
hacked into the oculus and we're just
streaming the data from the
accelerometer gyroscope is so sensitive
that it can tell if the person is
swaying backwards and forwards and and
their head is rotating in a way that it
shouldn't be rotating
so what we're looking at here is the
output of the oculus rift when we go and
take a look at post concussive blow what
we can see is a lot of sort of variance
in the data set that we're collecting
indicating that he took this hit and he
immediately was very very unsteady and
the oculus rift was capable of detecting
that unsteadiness and and showing us how
different he was from these lengths
we're trying to collect a compelling
objective data set that allows us to do
risk stratification for every plant so
for every player we can start to say
okay this is your risk of developing CTE
chronic traumatic encephalopathy and
here are all of the factors that are
affecting your risk of developing this
this debilitating and frightening
condition that is affecting a lot of
contacts for players
the scary truth is that every player
that steps on the field for an NFL game
they're sustaining 90 hits per game so
this is amounting to in a season more
than a thousand hits every year and
that's really worrying us because then
they're not showing acute signs of a
concussion so they go under the doctors
reader to optimize player welfare what
we really need to do is start to
understand how all of these little hits
might be adding up to a chronic
long-term brain injury or or syndrome
we're also hoping that as we collect
more and more data this becomes a tool
for allowing us to test new treatments
that are emerging in a very rigorous and
very quantitative way to actually you
know because the the corollary to being
able to see if performance is dipping
over time is that we can also see if
performance is starting to come up over
time and so this is really exciting for
therapeutics development as well
in the future what we're absolutely
going for is before every game after
every game do this five-minute thing it
uploads your data to the cloud and we
know how you're doing that's the way
that we're going to influence the field
and that's the way that we're going to
be able to make data-driven decisions
about returning to play or not returning
to play is by understanding each player
inside and out
you